they were so sure that i was covering up
sandy hook once i said i thought it
happened you talked about sort of the
psychosis that comes in with
seeing a lot of these conspiracies
seeing them play out and then maybe at
one point you were looking for
conspiracies in too many places because
you had seen the corruption is it that
the media and the government's fault
and that they lie so much they've been
caught lying so much that once they've
been caught you can't blame people
anymore i mean if i lied to my kids all
the time and then i told the truth about
something i said hey you got a new
bicycle out there in the yard or i got
you a new motorcycle or i you know i got
you a new skateboard and i'd lied to him
50 times there was never a skateboard
out there and they would finally say no
dad i don't believe it even though there
was a brand new skateboard or bicycle
out there i had more people walk on the
street and go well look at jesse smallit
that was staged you shouldn't have
backed off on sandy hook well i never
even quote i i always just question i
wasn't the guy that first brought up
sandy hook i questioned it i thought i
said i thought it happened that made
them assume he was like oh we got him
now he says it's real he must have lied
earlier